[Music]
highly contagious form of the bird flu
has been confirmed at several Southern
Nevada Parks thank you for joining us at
six I'm Brian Loftus I'm Denise Denise
says several agencies in fact sending
out Health alerts this week
urging everybody to avoid wild geese to
avoid other waterfowl Sasha Loftus spoke
with Park goers and health officials
today she joins us live from Sunset Park
with more Sasha
Denise and Brian officials say the two
geese that tested positive for that
strain of bird flu were found here at
Sunset Park you can see behind me there
are now signs up warning people to avoid
the animals and not feed them now the
Nevada Department of Wildlife sent out
an alert earlier this week after they
say the birds were tested in Washington
after they died other wild birds here in
southern Nevada have also showed
symptoms humans can catch highly
pathetic pathanogenic of Avian Influenza
or hpai but experts say the risk is low
some we spoke with here at the park say
this won't stop them from coming out but
they will take some precautions
it's extremely deadly for Birds yeah for
people it can cause extreme sickness as
well but again the likelihood of a
person a human actually Contracting the
virus is very very minimal I've just
been keeping him on leash holding him
close to me not really trying to get
towards the edge of the pond as much as
I can and just avoiding them as much as
I possibly can
now dogs can also get hpai if they eat a
bird that's infected people can carry it
and give it to their pets as well so
another reason to take precautions back
out here live Clark County says it's
Park and Recreation staff has been
stepping up patrols because of this
cleaning more removing a lot of the bird
droppings and removing any birds that
have died from these parks to make sure
this doesn't spread any further
reporting live at Sunset Park tonight
Sasha Loftus 8 News Now